en la naturaleza las abejas son sinónimo
de vida estos invertebrados tienen un
papel fundamental en la polinización de
cultivos que son el alimento de muchos
animales no obstante es un número se ha
visto muy reducido debido a la pérdida
de hábitat en la contaminación y los
pesticidas algo que representa un gran
peligro para la biodiversidad mundial la
verdad es que no puedo imaginar un mundo
en el que no estén las abejas presentes
porque como había mencionado y hoy como
misión dado muchos estudios alrededor
del mundo muchas de las especies que
viven alrededor nuestro dependen de las
abejas solo en europa las abejas
polinizan más de 4.000 variedades de
vegetales para el consumo humano y
contribuyen al 35 por ciento de la
producción agrícola del mundo pero
también tienen un papel fundamental en
la naturaleza con la polinización sin
ella no habría comida para los
herbívoros ni para los carnívoros que se
alimentan de ellos por lo que su
extinción desencadenaría en una crisis
alimentaria
naciones unidas- advierte que la especie
está en peligro se estima que el 40 por
ciento de los invertebrados polinizados
en especial las abejas y las mariposas
podrían desaparecer del mundo por eso
son muchos los apicultores que denuncian
el uso de pesticidas y herbicidas en los
campos de cultivo un problema que se
suma al cambio climático y a la
introducción indebida de especies de
otras partes del mundo américa latina'
el problema es que apis mellifera ha
desplazado en muchos casos a otras
especies de abejas tanto por competencia
por ejemplo porque ocupan muchos más
similares como porque sus poblaciones
han crecido muy diferente a las
poblaciones de abejas nativas de américa
latina' las abejas no sólo producen
alimentos son una de las principales
responsables de mantener la flora del
mundo que proporciona oxígeno sin estos
insectos son muchas las especies y
ecosistemas que estarían en peligro